good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today is a fun one
because we just slipped in a little
bunch for you someone um welcome to the
show thank you for having me
I'm excited to have you excited that
like I didn't tell that many people that
you were joining us Claudia did talk
about it but I kind of wanted it to be a
surprise like you tuned in and you just
got a hit a pinch hit a bunch on a
Monday can I be bunk one rumor that's
spreading oh sure a couple of people are
saying that I ditched the morning toasts
the last time that I was advertised my
mommy anyone say they did in the comment
section of today's picture of me three
minutes went by there were no comments
so of course I wrote Wow everybody must
hate me no comments and then a slew of
messages candidate said we don't want to
get excited when we're not sure if just
showing up so I just want to let the
record show I was ready to go oh yeah
okay maybe that's not what they're
referring to though they might be
referring to the time where you forgot
you were doing this and then but I came
but you came but you didn't like you
almost didn't show up so they don't get
excited mm-hmm
for the last you're right last time you
were supposed to come on it wound up
working out better if I did it with my
husband so we did that and it was like
better for a CEO schedule it's all about
it's all about CEO but now we get to
have you here today and now it's not
like stale like we just had you know
this is great this is great I'm you get
to be like in studio you look very uh
very appropriate leader today yeah but
no ripped jeans what's the occasion -
why do we deserve this respect okay I've
decided that I am no longer pursuing a
career in rock so because I'm not gonna
be a rock star I don't know if I need
the expose to me all the time yeah on
occasion but I do have my elbow pads
just in case I go skating that's you
never know when like you're gonna hop on
a skateboard and just need its chair an
elbow pad I'm sorry an elbow pad right
here it's pretty cool um though we miss
seeing your knee you know it'll be nice
not to be so distracted I mean no wish
is my command it's like
it's like when you gotta pay go to it so
oh my god oh my circulation in my leg
that's pretty petty petty qgs oh is that
that I'm a zipper in the back oh that's
a good one
it's only for a pedicure and if you're
getting a pedicure it just wear
sweatpants if you have enough time to
change your jeans just wear sweatpants I
understand but your sweatpants give off
a different impressed okay maybe other
people with the necklace on are talking
about you know like oh this lazy fat
[ __ ] I couldn't even put on jeans if you
have enough time to put on jeans as a
woman you can put on leggings as a man
you could wear shorts yeah but then
everybody makes fun of me I can't wear
shorts anymore
boobers it's October no I'm not allowed
to wear shorts on a plane I get [ __ ]
from people ooh
it's dirty you know what else is dirty
the whole [ __ ] plane you're dirty
regardless of you wearing shorts or not
okay right okay I will be okay with you
wearing shorts on the plane as long as
you tell me that you're one of those
people that the minute you get home from
the airplane should I wear of course
okay do whatever you want
uh and I'm not allowed to wear shorts
when it's nice out if it's October
just like the month of October is no
shorts yeah because it's fall nope and
this is very important fall is not
simply a date fall is when all of a
sudden it's a little chewier but if it's
70 degrees in the middle of October it's
not fall
it's got to be called something else
it's fall summer summer I don't know but
it's perfect why they're like yesterday
was just such a beautiful day in New
York mostly because there was no one in
the streets except for the Polish Day
Parade oh what a parade what a parade
himlen you saw it too I happen to be
crossing town it did get in my way and I
couldn't travel anymore but I was happy
to walk like through the parade so I
recorded the schvitz on 38th between
fifth and six in case anyone wants to go
rob them
no they can come and so I made a left
out of the studio and I'm on Fifth
Avenue and it's blasting like electronic
I felt like I was at Ultra like the
Polish really party hard they did it was
amazing they're just a fantastic how
display of Polish pride
fantastic display of Polish pride how
was the fits this fits was great another
great episode if you want to tune in
tomorrow morning there's a new one it
releases it around 6:00 in the morning
for that for that early commutes
it was fantastic it was great I'm so
glad to hear that and you're enjoying
being a sports reporter I am look the
people the people need to hear my voice
more often I can't come on the show
every day I know I can't it's just our
cross to bear that's why the shit's is
available via t NN listen if you're
interested in sports if you're
interested in comedy
look comedic sport you don't have to be
if you want to learn about sports if
you're a hardcore sports lover if you
want to just support me in all of my
various endeavors that's a great place
to go we're also turning very
experiential we're gonna have a tailgate
at the end of the month Oh make it right
that you will be coming to even I think
that it might cross with our sand wine
country tour well that hasn't been
planned yet so I might be able to plan
around you but I'm why am i tailgate
what are the deets the deets are that I
am partnering with NFL lifestyle okay I
am throwing tailgates that are free of
charge to people that love and respect
me in the schvitz and we have alcohol
sponsors and it's just a fun free way to
get nice and that's one can have a party
that's really fun I'm really free it's
really free cool completely free okay
I'll try and make it you wanna you want
a free free hot dog and yet Samantha
kosher course only the best course with
Thea be there of course and I'll be
there it's pretty cool
I think it's fun yeah sweet we're trying
things out it doesn't work we'll do
something else but I think it's I think
it's gonna be happy I think it's gonna
be a hit too well that's awesome I had a
really nice relaxing weekend but on
Saturday night I had such a Cleveland
tonight like I literally was about to go
on like Zillow and you're buy a house
outside of the city it was torture I
went to go to dinner 45 minutes in the
car to get to dinner to get to where I
was going only to see that there was no
tables so then we go to me pick a
different restaurant another 45 minutes
in the car
I literally just wanted to pull my eyes
out it was I don't I don't know why
people leave their house everyone should
just stay in at home drinking firstly
yeah whose fault that is I'm sorry
because saving money on award-winning
wine you're guaranteed to love has never
been easier with firstly mmm-hmm unlike
other wine clubs that guess about your
favorite wines firstly uses your
feedback in ratings to curate wine
selections personalized to your unique
tastes first leaf is so confident in the
quality of their wine they even have a
100% satisfaction guarantee that means
if you're not feeling a particular wine
bottle first leaf will cover it
completely we got started on firstly if
you take a wine quiz like they assess
your palate your vibes your specific
needs I feel like you would really love
a good wine quiz when they assess your
drinking privileged preferences from
sweetness to wine styles even how
adventurous you are they learned all
about what we like firstly then it
created an introductory 6-pack of wine
for me all for just twenty nine ninety
five seriously an introductory six-pack
of wine for 2995 when my bottles arrived
I tasted and rated them online firstly
is incredible I love their wines I love
the entire process and of course I love
the cost so if you want to sign up with
our link you'll get an exclusive intro
offer six bottles of wine for only 29.95
plus free shipping that's an incredible
deal just go to try firstly calm / toast
that six bottles of wine for only twenty
nine ninety five plus free shipping at
try first leaf calm / toast you guys I
love my first sleep wines and honestly
I'm never leaving the house again so I'm
gonna really need them six bottles for
2995 hot shows it's good stuff what I
was saying was that you know whose fault
it is that you had to go around the city
all the traffic your guys whose fault it
is bill the criminal how are you how are
things going you schmuck Keener's going
how are things going between like you
know yeah here's the thing I talk to him
all the time
and he never responds do you tag me in
your stories of course by the way John
Mulaney started posting pictures of
trash and blaming Bill DeBlasio does
that mean that John Mulaney saw my sores
or you think that this is like an old
trick I think it's like a general thing
like you
trash in the street and then you like
want to take a picture who do you tag
the mayor of course it's just like it's
common sense yes it's unbelievable yeah
it really is it really is unbelievable
it's disgusting I never it's also people
always say oh is there just trash
littering in the streets not like bags
the bags are at night but like why isn't
there a dumpster to put the bags and so
that the garbage man can then come and
empty the dumpster that's trooper thing
or like it's streets filled with
dumpsters yeah yeah yeah loose trash
like during the day you'll just be
walking around and like see like a chef
boyardee can just emptied out on the
street like what happened somebody was
eating a chef boyardee tripped it fell
but every day like somebody's tie their
shoes I'm the person who's like
littering a whole can of Chef Boyardee
but I think that we have now created a
society where were comfortable littering
we've created a city in which it's okay
to trash I completely agree unbelievable
but it's also on the people of course
it's on the people but it's on maybe
instead of it but someone needs me there
to pick up the trash I agree yeah where
maybe we should start finding the people
that all of a sudden God Emily drops her
whole chopped salad on the floor and
it's littered across 42nd Street
how would Emily gets a 15 dollar fine
yeah you'd have to see it you know yeah
maybe there should be a little less
traffic cops doing nothing and and more
traffic cops policing people throwing
food on the street don't even get me
started on the traffic cops and it's
like it's just it's a lose-lose
situation because it's like the traffic
cop doesn't want to be there yeah
hopping traffic nope like they went to
police school and they're doing traffic
yep so you don't want to yell at them
cuz it's like no one wants this so it's
it's it's a tough spot but I did figure
out and then we'll stop talking about
traffic cops they have so little power
people are so afraid they're like no you
can't make a left here you can't make a
left here you know what I make a [ __ ]
left there you know why they don't even
have a ticket booklet I get them out of
the way without I run them over that's
it they can't give me a ticket for
anything
I hope but like you can't go without
running the most somebody
on the other side they'll run over there
and all of a sudden yeah you need to
create a diversion diversion
a divine diversion that is a divine
barrier my friends yes okay well we have
some great stories today so I think it's
time some stories that we've been
talking about last week I want to get
your thoughts on right so it's time to
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast see ya
side stories are you ready for them of
course have you been keeping up with
what's going on in the world No so do
you know that Cody Simpson is dating
Miley Cyrus Wow do you know who Cody
Simpson what to do okay because things
went from just last week when Claudie
and I did the show and we were the first
to report the story because a toaster
saw them smooching in Malibu and we
actually cited our toaster as our news
source that was the first time we ever
did that we did that on Monday and a
week later their self eeing story and
calling each other baby and making each
other breakfast and it's just went from
zero to 60 you guys the romance
continues just a day after Miley Cyrus
was spotted kissing musician Cody
Simpson he took to his Instagram story
with a sweet selfie of the two on
Saturday quote pre swim breakfast
courtesy of baby the 22 year old caption
the black-and-white photo of himself
smooching the side of her face so like
all of a sudden they're full-fledged
couple and she also took to her
Instagram posted some photos of them
hashtag hot girl fall about how she's
doing you know what she wants to do
along with a long statement about how if
she were a man people would be talking
about her differently um I didn't read
the statement and I'm talking about her
positively because I think this is just
so exciting for teenyboppers everywhere
mm-hmm I have two things to say first of
all Miley Cyrus's instagram has become
incredibly premium over the last two to
four weeks I agree she became a true
lifestyle influencer I completely
pausing like in front of drops like in a
canyon and like angling herself for the
good light you know not not backlit like
you know like a real we revolve girl
she's put a lot of effort into that
Instagram lately I wonder what the what
the thought is behind that because
honestly right now I don't think that I
follow her I had unfollowed her because
it was just not my not my child minister
now it's good I should refile oh yeah
you should refile oh it's very good
the other thing who was she dating right
before Kaitlyn Carter yes and Kaitlyn
Carter follows me on Instagram
so we were so close to Miley for like
two weeks we were but being close to
Kaitlyn is so really cool yeah she seems
cool she's she's on the hills new
beginnings mom because she was married
to Brody and she just seems like a
fabulous girl great
so still use that connect sounds great
yeah I mean I don't know it's funny like
Instagram follower friends are funny
because like some of them you'll just
never speak to ever but it's like but
some of them like I can you know and I
you can start like a warm loving
relationship with you could best friends
for a lifetime that's so true so it's a
really weird thing and it's weird when
someone does follow you because you're
like you know oh we could maybe be best
friends or we could just be absolutely
true cool who's your best friend on
Instagram my best friend on Instagram or
the best friend that you've made through
Instagram that is such a tough question
my my most recent best friend on
Instagram would be Pete Alonzo of the
Mets
oh that's a good really we are good
friends we're having dinner on Thursday
I'm not gonna say where because I
learned my lesson with already sharing
where my studio is but great guy really
nice met their instruments and now we
have a real life friendship that's
really cool yes it is I'm excited for
you is it just the two of you guarding
dinner it is you're not bringing the
lives
no no steak you know oh so now you're
gonna tell us where you're gonna dinner
well anyways Cody and I they just wanted
to talk about cuz now they're like legit
couple status posting on Instagram like
a newly engaged bachelor couple and
while I'm here for it I'm also extremely
confused by it you know because she's
like that's so not her she's so private
but she's giving the public so much
maybe it is because she's becoming an
influencer it's seriously she's becoming
an influencer it's all connected
and I also think that when you're
private for so long maybe there was a
reason why she was private for so long
and now she's like she had that whole
statement where she's so proud of
herself and accepting of herself and has
come so far maybe she just wants to be a
complete open book and show everybody
what she's doing at all times yes as
opposed to like showing them the curated
image that she thinks that they should
see
I feel that and like generally speaking
that's a great way to live but I think
eventually it takes a toll on you and
then George and then she comes set
realization again if I think I gave
everything to the public and I had
nothing for myself you know don't say
it's waves it's the balance the fun part
about Instagram is that you can give as
much as you want to give if at some
point she's like [ __ ] this I don't want
to do this anymore
but now the expectation is so high yeah
but the expectation so high if she cares
about the expectation know like like
Jennifer Lawrence has no expectation
because she's not even on Instagram true
but I also haven't even thought of
Jennifer Lawrence and quite some time so
she's not really top of mind yeah if my
only went dark for a month he would be
talking about her being dark for a
moment but then when she came back he'd
be excited they'd be excited I feel that
okay well I'm excited for this happy
couple and I just want happiness for
Miley and Cody Simpson Simpson seems
like a cool dude and he sedate Kylie
Jenner so but like like ten years ago so
that's a really fun fun nice okay are
you ready for some more exciting couple
medium because country singer singer is
Mikey
sorry am i okay Michael country singers
Michael Rea and Carly parts are married
you guys this is so exciting because
you've you've been a fan of the show for
a while you know that we love and
respect the hell out of Carly parse
whose real name is Carly Pierce but
that's where we got our ears bars and
these two started dating a little while
ago and was just like a country-music
love song and now they're married and
it's really [ __ ] cute it sounds cute
you know don't know who either of them
are I wouldn't like necessarily expect
you to but she just came out with a song
like a nice in serum couple yeah they do
they also kind of look like a bachelor
couple he kind of looks like Blake the
lock' and she looks like a combination
of like three girls it's always the sit
on the leg photo yeah can they can't see
what we're looking at right no we're
looking at a picture that Michael Ray
posted I don't stir gram where they just
look cute it's a nice setup it was the
backwards hat that I think is like the
bachelor look is it like yeah like a
flat brim I got muscles like like one of
our you know yeah yeah
The Bachelor totally welcome country
music singers Michael Ryan Carly periods
have tied the knot in Tennessee
I can't even say Pierce parse the couple
dated for a year before saying I do
Sunday in front of 100 family and
friends at Drake wood farm near
Nashville the ceremony ceremony was held
indoors because of the rain but the
weather did not put a damper on the
Bohemian themed wedding Pierce 29 in
racer do you want exchanged personalized
vows and Bill Cody a country radio DJ
and announcer at Nashville's Grand Ole
Opry officiated they are really really
cute this is such like a country wedding
and Carly and and Michael Roy are and I
can't just call him Michael he's like
Michael right yeah they're both uh you
know hot and new on the country scene on
the way up like this could be the next
Garson Tricia
mm-hm next faith in Tim mm-hmm faith
yeah faith in to think yeah does she
have faith in to him oh for sure for
sure anyways I just think this is a
really sweet story and I love Carly
parse I don't know I just don't know who
she is if they seem lovely they really
do they look great I wish them all the
best
Carly Mike I know that if Claudia were
here she'd be so excited also speaking
of when Claudia gets back I'm not
talking about Taylor Swift on SNL today
because I want to wait for Claudia and
all the personnel sir no no she was on
SNL on Saturday Taylor Swift I feel like
we were supposed to watch it oh I fell
asleep Oh Saturday night
what a dream good habit nine was asleep
by 9:15 Wow
you know what's crazy yesterday I woke
up at the crack of 2:00 p.m. and then
last night I fell asleep like by 11 2
p.m. I woke up so late I woke up at 1:45
yesterday what times you got a bad two
and a first thing welcome at 12:45 in
great blackouts yeah and I just have
like webOS actually I've been waking up
a lot earlier naturally recently um
which has just been like really sad
because I love to sleep
but yesterday I finally accomplished it
another tour another cheaper that's very
but usually if I wake up at 2 I won't
fall asleep till 4 and
I fell asleep so early it's the
blackout's Claudian I found in our last
4 min that we were sniffing a little bit
too late mm-hmm so in this apartment we
don't have full blackouts yeah like I
don't know just not full yeah so I wake
up naturally but like with sunlight I
don't think I can sleep past 10:30 yeah
I mean it's nicely I've recently been
waking up earlier on the weekends which
it it has its pros and cons you know you
feel more like a person but yeah so just
more time to eat that's what it is
yeah you wake up on Saturday you wake up
on Sunday it's like let's go get brunch
and then you know like drink yourself
into a coma and eat so much terrible
food if I just woke up at 2:00 I would
have waited until dinner and I'd be so
much skinnier by SELEX later all it is
is it's more time to eat
you just hit the nail on the head how
you present yeah my whole arm cracked
with that nail on the head that's how
passionate we are about the subject ok
next story a bit of Kardashian news
because love them I watch the episode
last night it was so good it was it was
so interesting this whole this whole
season isn't really good but this
episode it just had so many interesting
factoids that I'll talk about when
Claudia gets back but one we saw behind
the scenes of North West going to Joe
Josie was house and basically everything
that we said on the show was exactly
true about what happened which was that
North was so shy Joe Joe was like an
animal and yeah I was watching with Zach
I mean like I guess he's never heard of
Josie I mean he just didn't know like
who he was looking at he was like how
old is this person - like she's 15 and
then later in the episode when she was
acting like a 40 year old woman I was
like she's literally 35 but he was like
I thought you said she's 15 she defies
all age how language she she's 15 but
like there are some conspiracy theories
out there that she's a 40 year old
change okay so like Jackson from totally
she's definitely 15 but there's
something about her that's just so 35
you know sure she was just she just like
was acting like the babysitter who got
dressed up like no like someone who also
needs to be sat on mm-hmm
it was just a crazy episode and then
Scott
Thea and Courtney and Finland was just
so interesting that is a very
interesting dynamic it was also so
strange but it was a great episode
anyways Kylie Jenner and Khloe
Kardashian run into their exes Tyga and
Lamar Odom at an LA nightclub okay Kylie
is trying to get away from Tyga but they
just keep going to the same spot and now
I'm confused Kylie Jenner and Khloe
Kardashian were spotted partying it up
together at high lunge in West Hollywood
the same club that Jenner's ex boyfriend
Tyga and Kardashian's ex-husband Lamar
Odom were at dressed in a hot pink dress
Jenner arrived at the club on Saturday
evening with her sister and Khloe shared
a video of the siblings together on her
Instagram story Lamar was spotted
leaving the same venue with his
girlfriend Sabrina Parr the sisters
arrived around 1:00 a.m. while Tyga was
already inside at the time
the rapper reportedly left about an hour
later so do you think that this is
another coincidence because Travis and
Kylie are on a break apparently
allegedly I'm still not 100% convinced
and Kylie like happened to me at the
same studio spot that tygo is out last
week but then she released a statement
that they have nothing to do with each
other and now they're at the same club
yes I definitely think that these are
coincidences
I can't imagine is there really only one
club and you know I know but maybe
there's only one Club in LA that really
famous people and I want to go to like
if there there may be multiple clubs but
when you're that level of Fame I think
you'd want to go to the best one yeah
and I'm sure I'm sure that they have
very similar mutual friends i I don't I
I just can't imagine that there would be
anything going on between them I can't
imagine it it's I don't I don't it's
just not believable to me yeah
especially because Kylie from afar and
Travis and stormy just seemed like so
great like I don't
it doesn't even this like distance or
whatever it is this it's not a breakup
whatever this is a break it just seems
like and it makes sense they're so young
like they were hit with so much money
and so much fame so quickly and like
Kylie and Travis I just think want to do
different things so like maybe it's like
a a break so that
he can hang out with his friends well I
don't know I don't want to speculate
things but yeah I just I don't
anticipate this being a break where
either of them would ever be ever be
seeing other people like they seem like
great people and great parents yeah and
I feel like don't you feel like when
someone breaks or you're on a break with
someone like it's worse to go back to
the person you were dating it's worse
for you're broken up with person if you
go back to the person you were dating
before versus just moving on with
someone else that's a full that's like
an I'm angry at you I'm doing this this
is like I was never over this person
yeah they've been in the back of my mind
this whole time yeah which is most if
she was like out spotted like with
someone else I wouldn't think it was so
crazy but this is just so crazy I just I
I don't I don't think that it's true but
I don't think that is true I agree I
don't think that it's true you guys it's
like they want us to believe this
narrative and I'm I refuse to believe
it's quickly that's what it is like
that's more clicky than Kylie spotted
with Tyga again yeah everybody wants to
know what that juice is and like Lamar
Odom mean there it's just a wild
coincidence
there's no way no way yeah anybody is
still keeping like actually here's one
thing that I've noticed and it goes to
the like Kendall going to what part did
she go to with Yoon's
a unis unis she went to oh why Justin
Bieber's wedding she won with Eunice
that's hers that guy Faye oh is that not
Courtney's ex-boyfriend no oh [ __ ] but
it is because um there is an episode of
Q of Keeping Up with the Kardashians
where Kylie and Kourtney fight over this
friend Faye who's Courtney who's cut
who's Kendall and Courtney fight over
this friend Faye and it's Kendall's
friends okay oh my god my brain is like
spazzing on the Kardashian it's very
confusing all that I was trying to say
oh she do with you is once they become
friends with someone and this is very
smart of them they keep them very very
very very close yes like French Montana
yeah because even though I'm sure that
they love French Montana but I'm sure
that French Montana heard some [ __ ] and
if you don't keep them close they talk
[ __ ] about you
and that's the exact same reason why
this bizarre friendship between like
Scott Disick and Sofia Ricci and
Kourtney Kardashian like that's not a
normal thing to go on vacation like that
but like you you kind of have to yeah
like once somebody's introduced into the
like the back ends of the Kardashian
lifestyle I feel like there's so much
drama and juice in there yeah
that you need to keep your friends close
but your enemies closer almost almost
also weirdly Kylie and Tiger are now
sort of related because Rob has a kid
with China who has a kid with Tyga yes
so I actually think it might be like a
form of incest if they were to hook up
again they just or not
yeah there's no way there and by the way
there's no way on God's green dilly
dally earth that they are they're not
there's no way so they just happen to
all be at the same club which just says
to me that when we're in LA next week
like we have to go to hide also no
totally
that's all I'm learning from this story
that there's only one cool Club in LA
and I gotta get there even though I just
hate clubs
I was watching Kardashian's last night
and they went to Vegas for the twins
birthday Malika and Khadijah and they
were in the club and nothing has ever
looked less fun to me in my life clubs
are really not fun when you see them on
TV because the only way that you have
fun in a club is when you're either like
so [ __ ] up yeah like when you're just
like in your element you're like yeah
music but like when you see it on TV
it's like I think why would people go to
that and I always have this image in my
head think about a club night and just
shut all the music and then think about
what the [ __ ] people are doing like I
feel the way that we like contort our
body because we hear a certain noise
it's just like the idea of dancing in
general know and like dancing around a
little table yes in really if you're a
woman like really uncomfortable she's in
an even more uncomfortable trust
probably where you're like wanting to
sit on the bank kept it in like your
Spanx are gonna show and like dancing
around like a picture of cranberry shoes
that's like 300 dollars yeah yeah no
it's it's crazy and like I love them I
love a good club but you have to have
the you have the right night the right
music the right people and you have to
be so significantly intoxicated yeah I
feel that I actually had like a crazy
idea for my birthday that
run by you later I don't know if I'm
gonna do it but it was I think he would
really like it anyways are you ready for
our next story because it's an
interesting story and I hadn't heard
about it sooner go to fashion designer
Virgil a blow just created a furniture
line for IKEA cool isn't that a cool
story collaboration the wait for the
Virgil a blow X IKEA collection is
almost over I didn't even know there was
a wait cuz I didn't even know there was
a collection it was announced on Tuesday
that the eye-catching collaboration
between the two design powerhouses
titled marker ad which means marked in
Swedish will officially launch in IKEA
stores on November 1st so this is so
cool and I know for a fact like my
husband is gonna try and procure a piece
from this question because he loves
Virgil and he likes IKEA and he also
loves a good collection he loves a good
collection oh my god he just got some
collection stuff from like kiss next
nobody tell you about it it's pretty
cool it is very cool yes I've never seen
him be so excited about anything in his
life
it must be how like toasters feel when
they caught that toast merch which just
flew off the shelves cuz he said it sold
out in ten minutes
much like toast merch and by the way you
guys perfect time to update you that if
you didn't get what you wanted because
it sold out within minutes um it will be
available again in two weeks we're
ordering crazy quantities because the
demand was just out of this world
well the merch was [ __ ] sick it was
like this that's kind of it not the
difference so like when Zach showed me
the note no blue merch I was just no
good kid
it was sick I just can't imagine him
wearing a big neon orange sweater I know
but then he said it was the only color
left no I mean that or no it only came
in two colors that color like lime green
honestly the kalam is really sick and
I'm gonna steal all of it yes I told my
taking out the hat is pretty good that
troubling favorite one thing that he
does want yeah
but should I wear a neon orange I feel
like you could yeah but then I just like
look like a traffic cone yeah or you
could just get the TMT pink one
that cuz it's a great color pink cuz
it's like more of a corally pink I told
the core the teal one I know even Ben
didn't get one I didn't get anything I
got nothing I got completely shafted I
got a pen you even sell pens
yeah but they come free with the pouch
isn't eating at the pouch nope no pouch
just a loose pen
I found a loose pen on the floor and I
took it honestly he's an incredible pen
I was using it to write something and
like Andalus and it's like a crisp pen
and I felt like I was signing the
Declaration of Independence it's like
the perk it's like such a perfect
ballpoint it comes with the vinyl pencil
cases which are still available there a
lot of the accessories are still
available at chop morning toast calm but
if you want to get those those
sweatshirts and some of those more
apparel items those are being restocked
in two weeks with heavy quantity so
don't fret you're gonna get what you
want and like there's absolutely no way
it could go that fast again no it can
are the Pens refillable I know unless
you unless you're a pen like engineering
you know how to do that see that's
what's always so interesting to me app
engineer yeah it should be very easy or
or just I think that it is very easy to
refill the ink in a pen the second
appendage is like a new pen
okay personally I don't think I've ever
seen a pen till its death you know
I'll lose it before that it's like
finishing a huge chap stand you lose it
before you finish it but then you find
it and it has no ink or it's dry oh is
that what it is yeah just dry yeah if
you uh if you write on the bottom of
your shoe it'll roll it to the to a wet
side hmm I usually just do it on the
palm of my hand no you got to do bottom
of the shoe it'll roll it mmm not my
shoe but your shoe something with a
rubber sole mm-hmm just an interesting
factoid that I thought you might find
interesting it's very interesting just
like this virgil ikea story did you know
about this I had no idea this is very
cool I am a big fan of IKEA you are yeah
the store is absolute torture torture
chopper go but here's the problem the
stores only torture if you are for
whatever reason going into IKEA without
a game plan if you're going into IKEA
like oh I'm just gonna like peruse
around and find what I need you will
never find what you need ever because
there are 9,000 rugs on 10 floors
there's a hundred different variations
of this one lamp you're never gonna find
what you need but if you do research
beforehand and then you go in and you
find your stuff it's actually great the
downside is the building piece yeah no
you've got a splurge for a builder but
that's right so cheap the
there truly is very very cheap and if
you're not fat [ __ ] like me it lasts but
unfortunately when you jump on your bed
the bed breaks oh no the our bed is
actually Zacks from when he had a
bachelor pad
and it's from Ikea and so we've had it
for like is it working six years yeah
but we need to get a new one because
it's so ugly yeah but at least it still
works yeah it works know that the
problem is the IKEA beds it's all the
wooden panels that go under your
mattress
yeah and so one big one bad step Oh
crunch hasn't happened to us yet crunch
crunch
um okay a big fan of Ikea big fan of
Virgil really cool stuff I'm interested
to see because IKEA is sort of a
discount brands and he is the total
opposites
he's a premium premium man he is premium
but like his clothes are really
streetwear accessible cool like I feel
like it actually I'll show you some of
this not accessible oh you mean the
prices yeah but whenever a designer
collabs with a brand like it's always
keeps the brand's prices so even like no
miss key no hmm it's hmm prices
Commonwealth I think so I snagged a few
items but I had to go through like back
doors I understand Salman H&M its H&M
prices which is why it's so exciting for
the customer it's exciting for the
customer but it's also so these are
gonna be IKEA prices yeah okay I mean
I'm excited to see like what do we have
any idea what's in this collection here
you guys will post this picture to our
Instagram it see it's like he's selling
those bags that like that's this thing
the quotes I don't know it's very IKEA
very IKEA I mean little - IKEA if you
ask me I mean I mean make that chair I'm
excited for you to post these pictures
because this collection but I love
Virgil sweet guys I could be kind no I
love him too also this article
introduced uh Virgil as Justin Bieber's
go to fashion designer which is like
he's so much more than that so much more
than that he's the the king of elevate
the king about the best friend of Kanye
yep dressed Kendall for the Met Ball
like yeah go on
okay there's a final story I chose
because it's pertinent to the situation
obviously but it's also pertinent to our
situation because fun fact
this is that we used to hold a host a
river day laughter show yes
loved it and and the new Riverdale
trailer has come out at comic-con and it
shows the moment when Archie learns his
dad played by Luke Perry is dead and
it's your real tear-jerking tearjerker
you died a while ago we Perry died a
while ago but this is the first time
they're in there this is how they're
handling and then the show in this
season oh you're saying that from wait
so he knows that he died in the show no
he doesn't are you sure yeah no they
hadn't like really a dress like Fred
Andrews yeah
oh I understand okay yeah I guess I
forgot about that so it's really sad the
funeral footage um and Riverdale comes
back on Wednesday that's Joe's [ __ ]
crazy and I'll tell you why I'm like my
mom put it best she they're big fans
sorry they saw her household but they
can't really watch it as much now
because it went from like fun dramatic
highschool drama to really [ __ ] scary
yeah and it's just like it I get it it's
like thrilling and shock factor but the
where the show started to where it is
now it's like all like Dungeons and
Dragons and death and yeah just like
it's so crazy and I'm just like waiting
for the moment when magic comes magic
never coming in the show hey here's the
thing I wasn't magic is coming and as
much as I agree with you it went from
something that it wasn't to what it is
now
it actually hasn't because the first
season was a murder mystery and then
with this new season of the game and the
Dungeons & Dragons like I thought it was
definitely gonna be magic something
weird is going on something
unexplainable I was like I was like how
was all this stuff happening like it
seems like hocus pocus yeah
but by the last episode everything made
sense there was an explanation for
everything and a person behind
everything so it's and that was even
crazier it was like what we thought was
having we thought was unfathomable
there's gonna be no possible explanation
for this but they tied it all together
so well and I just like it expanded what
I thought the show was capable of they
did it's just like Penelope blossom is
like a wild murderer it's just like I
don't know it's just like the way that
the show went
and like became all about this like
random drug cartel and the need for real
estate it was just like a bizarre like
where they're supposed to be magic in
this show No so what happened they were
gonna introduce it but then Sabrina the
Teenage Witch went to Netflix instead of
the CW so there's no there's gonna be no
crossover but when Sabrina was gonna be
a show on CW because it was by writer
Ross also then I think they were gonna
have the worlds meet like suite life on
deck with Hannah Montana
you know great of course I know so but
we're not gonna get that crossover and
it's funny I watched Sabrina and Netflix
I think I'm like I just people that yeah
and it's like like the same way that
you'd watch a soap opera and like just
like keep watching it's like shitty good
TV yeah I enjoyed it it's just like a
little strange but that's a lot of magic
did you watch the politician know you
shed yeah but I don't know what I'm
going to I spoke about this with Claudia
on a the most recent patreon episode of
the podcast where I've seen I've had a
patreon.com session wearing to us they
check it out
yeah um I've started maybe 20 shows like
watch the first two episodes mm-hmm but
then when I'm not alone Claudia finishes
them so I never get to see oh and I
never really have time like what am I
gonna do go in the other room and watch
a show it's like now I'm watching Sex in
the City for the ninth time and it's
just like I can't [ __ ] stand that
show yeah we talk about sex in the city
I know that we're we have an agenda to
go to but yeah Terry Bradshaw awful
thing about the internet we it waits for
us sorry Bradshaw he's one of the worst
characters he's the most 1000%
none of this show makes any sense it's
like she and big never belong together
don't belong together and he is
constantly giving her what she wants but
nothing is ever good enough for her yeah
and also he's constantly being honest
with her and like telling her where he's
at and like not leading her on like not
being a fuck-boy and she just like
refuses to see the writing on the wall
yeah and like her questions like from a
guy's perspective
are like kind of mean towards men I
don't know she just like makes men seem
like things like animalistic like gross
like we we have emotions too and like
just because she thinks that all that we
want to do is like go out and like [ __ ]
everyone that we see like that's just
not true which is yeah weird weird like
like lens into the brain of her and her
character and if she tries to smoke in
one more person's apartment I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill myself yeah she needs to
hear what wait it doesn't matter what
here it is if somebody doesn't smoke in
their apartment why are you smoking in
their apartment you're pretending
offended that you're smoking in their
apartment middle smart like nice on a
bar it's like someone's apartment with
their furniture that like it's gonna
soak up the smell of your cigarette like
put it out like we just watched this
episode where they go to one of bigs
friend's Park Avenue apartment and they
[ __ ] and he gives her a Judith Leiber
bag and it's like not even good enough
for her and then she like tarnishes the
name of Judith Leiber totally it's just
funny like she's supposed to be like
this like big writer fashionista like
she doesn't know that you just gave her
like a $10,000 bag yeah no but she knows
but she just like was anti with Judith
what Judith Leiber stood for and it's
like it took him Kardashian to like
brings you to sleep her back from the
dead and it's the cutest it's the best
brand ever and it's so not right what
this show did to it it's even but that's
fine like whatever like she's really
upset
great she's upset that she totally it's
just so weird and she's just like
they're like oh I like these women are
so not like me let me smoke no miss you
can't [ __ ] smoke in my home go to the
terrace nice yeah so offended that
somebody asks you to go on the terrace
it's not like it didn't show you're like
a dog they didn't keep smoke you smoke
on a terrace
no I totally agree I don't care what
year it is you're legally oh that's a
smoke doesn't mean you have to smoke in
my house when I don't smoke I hear you
buddy and I watch Sex in the City from
the beginning I mean like we know she is
the worst person the worst character on
TV infusion infuriating to watch
infuriating and you're supposed to like
want good things for her and
keep watching though yeah why am I still
watching what is because the rest of the
show is good like the friends are cool I
like the friends you know the scenes are
cool the the clothes are cool the Z is
just the part that sucks
I don't like whenever she liked us like
that typing question I just like I hear
you well if you're loving today's
episode of the morning toast with boy
with no job I'm happy to tell you that
it is brought to you by cope re a brand
that we love here at the morning toast
we've talked about our love for Co
parties aluminum free coconut deodorant
before I love coke re for a myriad of
reasons but mostly because it got me off
of chemical deodorants and now using a
natural deodorant where you don't feel
the effects of natural deodorant and you
don't smell and you do not smell and now
they've got an amazing new scent called
driftwood and it's the first charcoal
deodorant from Co party so you've heard
us talk about their organic coconut tea
or in the beach in gardenia scents and
the fragrance free version but now they
have a new driftwood scent that smells
like sandalwood and cedar wood with
middle notes of zesty clove that sounds
delicious
it says hey tell them cook with it
probably probably eat it it's also made
with activated but you know I'm not
gonna make that claim dounia's it's also
made with activated charcoal which works
to girag sweat and toxins and absorb
odor causing bacteria exactly what you
want in a deodorant parries coconut
children is a cleaner alternative to
traditional you turrents it's aluminum
free vegan and does not contain silicone
sulfates parabens GMOs or baking soda
I'm so grateful to kawari for alerting
me about what I was putting into my
armpits and organ that is very close to
another important organ the breasts and
we just shouldn't be doing that so well
aluminum free deodorants are where it's
at and cope re has a myriad of options
for you to choose from go to cope re
beauty calm slash toast to save five
dollars off your first or deodorant
order when you subscribe that's cope re
Kop a RI Beauty calm sash toast cope re
beauty.com / toast truly sign on and
smell amazing and feel amazing to cope
re Beauty calm / toast to get five
dollars off your first tree odor in you
guys I can't remember recommend this
highly enough and also while you're at
Campari BT calm
they have some other four other
wonderful beauty products that I love
the I was never a fan of the idea of
organic deodorants right things that
bugs you down it's not it's just like
when I think of I just find it hard to
believe that something non chemical it
can make me not smell mm-hmm and like
you think you need like the big gun you
need something to make sure that I don't
smell mm-hmm but this idea of my lymph
nodes are right there like why am i
rubbing right like some weird ass [ __ ]
on my lymph node instead of a beautiful
coconut like I should be massaging my
lymph node with a coconut
you really should and kapowee is the way
to do it go for it okay so those were
the facts I swear ease now I have been
here I'm gonna get him all of your
questions and what splendors we have a
question that actually I want to ask you
as well how's your live method
experience going the live method is
amazing I don't go enough you know Matt
from the web method is 8 plus the whole
operation is a plus the attention to
detail on personal training and like I
went in there and I said to him because
like my main focus
it's not even weight loss its
flexibility like I don't want to even as
I'm here I'm going like this and my
[ __ ] arm cracks yeah like that means
that I don't know he's my whole body
dormant and like I'm very I'm like I
play a ton of sports all the time mhm so
I definitely am athletic but I just
don't know like I just I just want to be
a little bit more flexible and so
everything that we do is like towards
stretching my body yeah core and I don't
know I couldn't recommend it enough but
I I need to go far more than I do I know
it's so hard like well it's hard when
you're there and then it's also hard to
it's just hard to get there it's hard to
schedule that appointment and go it's
not like once you're there it's like
alright like he's working my ass off oh
my god no I had a session last week
where it was deadly deadly really yeah
it was so hard it's hard I mean you you
you it's like you get what you pay for
and like sometimes how like have a bad
week of eating but I still like how I
look and I'm like oh that's cuz I've
been going to the lab method and they're
shaping me up yeah and who knew that I
had such amazing deadlift form I don't
know if you've seen any of the video
but like I could enter a deadlifting
competition you should I'm a deadlift
her
you really should can you talk to us
about your flat iron hair experience
sounds like you've been having a lot of
experiences recently I learned something
that day what did you I am a horrendous
negotiator
Claudia sometimes will come your hair is
wrong right now right it's long on top
yeah it's just some no but it's longer I
could use a haircut you could use a
haircut I mean evil won't get attacked
without iron no I will that's the
problem because I'm a bad negotiator
okay
every single time Claudia offers me a
deal that ends in a back rub it's always
do this I'll rub you back afterwards and
guess what the back rub never comes so
this is the classic example I get home
caught my head really hurts like oh okay
um let me flat iron your hair and then
I'll rub your head flat irons my hair
didn't you feel like you were finally
achieving that like emo kid aesthetic
that isn't really on the inside of you
yeah but I couldn't I was going to
dinner I'm like yeah I have to shout
maybe if we did this before the Avril
Lavigne concert or the blink 182 concert
or one of the numerous Punk experiences
that have had this month yeah but we did
it before dinner at the Polo bar yeah
which no I just needed to shower and get
get rid of it but there was something I
I didn't hate it mm-hmm I didn't hate it
okay there's probably somewhere in
between my my curly locks and you need
like a little betrayed betrayed yeah
everyone once that's like what we're
always doing it get here I got that new
Dyson blow-dryer that Claudia has yeah
and I'm figuring it out so far I like it
but so far I haven't found like a great
enough hairstyle to justify the price
but I'll keep everyone I'll keep
everyone posted also I got a facial
yesterday great and I learned so much
about my skin like I feel like everyone
thinks that I know what I'm talking like
I know what I'm doing but apparently
I've been doing everything wrong like my
entire life so how does my skin look
today great honestly I I'm on a new path
and I'm really excited about it because
I've been using like heavy creams
because I just feel like the more
moisture the better and I just like love
moisturizing my face but I've been
that's not the answer like at all
apparently I have oily skin and like I
should
using oil-free moisturizer like no one's
ever told me to use anything oil-free in
my life because you think oils are good
but I think I produce enough oil I have
a really really sad reality for you hmm
look at my skin I don't we can get a
zoom but do I have great skin there are
very few pimples very few i 0 skin
regimen
zero yeah you know why because it's
genetics yeah also but your amazing me
you don't wear makeup every day like if
you want to make up every day it would
affect your skin in a negative way but
like I have to wear makeup every day so
then you have to take the necessary
precautions to help to offset this is an
incredibly true statement you know if I
wanted nothing if I didn't wear makeup
any day ever my skin would be so great I
wouldn't want to do that much in one
statement the facialist also told me she
was like do wear foundation I was like
yes and she was like you should not wear
foundation it is literally a mask so
you're walking around with like this is
heavy mask on your face like all day and
she does like and it's not on your skin
can't breathe and so now I'm like I'm
wearing a mask
I'm masked singer I've never even but
it's one of the mask singer it's this
big big person dressed like a green bean
let's say you have no clue who it is
sing sound amazing
you don't find out who that [ __ ]
person is for episodes really yes we
watch the whole episode and did not find
out who that person was in the same
episode do you do infuriating that is
yeah that is that's pretty that is
terrible like I'm just on a casual
watcher I'm watching one show yeah he
can't tell me who the person I just
listened you sing is yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] like it
today it is yeah that like this person
enjoys grilled cheese and went to
Harvard sat and is six foot six who
could it be
actually that's pretty good clues and
they're famous already we have no idea
oh we know nothing they could be as
famous and by the way Fame
is so stretched to like it's famous in
like every sense of the word like I
Kim Jung who by the way everywhere
ken Jeong that Kim Eddie John Oh
everywhere everywhere he's getting paid
to do everything he's just America's
host these days he's on the mask singer
yeah and that he was just like hell-bent
that this person was nathan lame and I'm
just thinking myself Nathan Lane is not
even remotely on my radar for somebody
in the masked singer yeah really
annoying people are seconding that
Olivia jade is one of the people I just
ate but that's the exact point and if I
don't have enough time to invest yeah
this is a singing show show me that the
[ __ ] singer is at the end of the show
you know what I totally feel I've never
even tried to watch it because it seems
like infuriating don't okay good I
didn't want to yes sir
no that's good did you ask me a question
there did I tell you once again yeah I
don't think there was a question I just
said I'm wearing a mask I'm a mess okay
yes well thank you so much for joining
us where can everyone if they want to
hear more from you bye you with you
check you out
boy with no job always I will not say
anything more but there's some strong
content coming just stronger than normal
that's all that I'll say that's exciting
yes it is so if you want more of me more
of my face that's certainly there if you
want more of my voice the shit's the
Schmidt's the Fitz at the Fitz on
Instagram even if you're gonna go there
you're gonna see a lot of sports means
and content and news and if you're not
into that that's fine there's a little
link in the bio click it and you can
listen to me
I sound exactly the same as I do here
I'm just talking about sports so maybe
you find the sound of my voice
soothing mmm-hmm maybe you find it
infuriating in which I wouldn't
recommend clicking on the link in the
box but maybe maybe that someone that
you love loves sports and you know once
a sport experience this is there with
them it's heavy sports and I like not to
pat ourselves on the back we're
incredibly knowledgeable this is like
the same exact way that you guys have
like become like big in the space
commenting on pop culture okay you
weren't on TV before you just like know
a lot about pop culture superfan and
they're now just like talking about it
we know everything
there is to know about all sports that
are important to us that's good so if
you want to one a little more it's
called the shits
check it out podcasts or anywhere you
can find the toast podcast not on
YouTube anyways thank you guys so much
for tuning in we are back tomorrow with
Claudia and Margo the gangs back
together
Wednesday is Yom Kippur so just pray for
us you guys ask
it's literally like on my mind all the
time I'm so dreading it I love you um
keyboard I know that's such a weird
thing to say but it's like the one time
every other religion like from what I
understand Christianity if you do
something wrong you can say sorry like
whenever you want you can go to the
church you can turn the other cheek and
you can say sorry there's one time where
it seems like the gates of heaven are
open and we're allowed to say sorry for
things and that's Yom Kippur so I'm
actually know like write down all the
things that I wish that I didn't do and
say sorry and move on with my life yeah
but like the fasting part yeah but it's
also like a nice jumpstart it's not it
it's not no it's the opposite because I
miss you up so much you'll eat so much
for dinner that night more than you
would have eaten in a whole day and then
the next thing you feel horrible so you
just want to eat you're right and it's
just it's it's not it does not help you
diet how about we do this how about we
pre fast just have like grilled chicken
and then post fast no because the whole
time well the whole time while I'm
passing I'm gonna be like kicking myself
for not having eaten more the night
before yeah but like I don't know
and even like now like we don't have to
be animals and have 9b no we don't have
any animals but when you're that hungry
like yeah I'm gonna be in that it's so
fun what a great meal it's the best meal
break fast to breakfast for dinner we
should do more often it's so funny you
are breaking the fast of your slumber
that is the that is breakfast yeah it's
just but why do we call it Breck it's
break breakfast breakfast it's not like
a brick
what's a brick no but it's a break fast
but it's breakfast and what's lunch
what does lunch mean I don't know maybe
like a munch dinner I don't know weird
I'm saying like breakfast clearly means
your brain and fast of your slumber yeah
lunch like should be called like midday
bite yeah MGB yeah and then dinner like
end fast and fist em fist alright cool
well that's our chef yeah giving you
something to think about on this Monday
morning we will see you tomorrow
everyone have a great day we love you
you